well hey how's it going i'm here with
alexa hey and we learned recently about
the sweet game called gravity ghost um
made by IV games this pretty sweet
little game that i tested out um just
over the last day and i actually
finished it i think it's a great little
game i really enjoyed it and I know
you've seen a little bit about it yeah
I'm very interested I know you were
talking a lot about it so I'm really
glad we get to play it now yeah so we're
gonna play through a little bit of my
continued game and just kind of seats on
the levels I don't give away too much
now so kind of just scrape the surface
of this game so this very story heavy
right it is it has a really nice cute
story it's kind of focusing on a this is
cute it is cute it's got a wonderful art
so I really love the art it's about a
little girl and kind of befriending a
fox basically it's kind of where it's
revolved around and here's the main hub
you'll probably see a lot of wow yeah
it's actually a really large world
there's you know there's a lot of
different different places you can go
but at the same time most these levels
are pretty short okay even though
there's all this game I turned through
it in about two hours and I know there's
an achievement to speedrunning the game
in less than 50 minutes so wow it can be
done quickly but I think this game is
kind of more of the thing that you're
supposed to just relax and sit down and
chill and enjoy I don't think it's meant
to be speedrun really i do like relaxing
games and this looks and feels relaxing
this music is really nice too yeah it's
really lovely I don't think it has too
many tracks you know I probably heard
the same track a lot but I liked it so I
didn't it didn't really bother me too
much but yeah this is the main hub it
looks like I'm kind of in a space world
and that really works out because I
would say the main comparison you can
make to this game would be probably
Super Mario Galaxy or something like
that because it's based on gravity this
is the only one I haven't gotten the
star to so I thought we'd start here
because I haven't
see not yet some there uh oh let me get
the mouse out of the way this is super
cute even though it's oh so yeah it's
kind of showing you the world and then
when i move it zooms in on me you'll
notice probably instantly I've got a lot
of furry friends following me I was
going to say is that like a trail of
just rabbits following you yeah I've
collected them over the course of the
game you'll find there's like a rabbit I
found like a salamander a bird did I do
well they kind of just hang out with me
but when you collect them and you meet
them up with their bones you unlock a
piece of the story there they're both
I'm assuming that's a story point the
fact that you bring them to their bones
that's right i think a lot of this the
story is kind of revolving around maybe
some pieces of death or acceptance and
where you go after that so it's it's a
it's got i was much deeper than i
thought it would be I'll tell you that
right now I was really surprised by it
but yeah it looks like you you basically
get rewarded for kind of helping these
people out with their figuring out what
they want to do so yeah you can see
there's these little things i can grab i
can easily lose my place here I want
that little thing oh you also notice
this white trail behind me that's my
hair my hair gives me some extra powers
I'll show you some of them now that's a
lot of hair actually yeah i get i have
all sorts of sweet hair and so I'm
changing right now from like pink too
green to blue to white those are all
various skills that I get from and I can
kind of change the world's around me
from ice to liquid and things like that
which is really neat so what I'm trying
to do in all these levels is unlock the
star which I which I did grab already in
this in this level and you know that
because the door that I that was closed
earlier is now open so I like grabbed it
but I want to try to get this orb this
the orbs increased the length of my hair
and I need there we go I got it and I go
hair and I need that hair so I
change though so I can change the worlds
because those costs hair so i need to a
lot of emphasis on here yeah it's a big
part of it and it's beautiful hair so
the the piece that we just said is that
about the average length of each little
yeah some of them are really short and
some of them are our this is another
really short one so you can see I'm just
basically this is called the grandfather
clock and what I'm doing right now
hopefully this isn't too much of a
spoiler because we'll see what happens
I'm connecting an animal with its bones
and because I did that it should unlock
a little piece of story oh yeah it's
that's really cute I love oh and then it
gives me all these little worms as like
a thank you um yes I know it's hard to
kind of perfectly jump cuz it is gravity
based on circling this thing that I'll
try to pick up more of them now yeah
damn oh you have all the good one yeah I
got pretty lucky on that one I just
think it's so funny that you're like
like flying through space with a bunch
of animal goes so that's the ghost and
gravity goes yeah we'll go basically
yeah and so yeah you can see all the
different animals i collected once you
get the animal so there's animals hiding
in the levels and once you collect those
then you can reunite them with their
bones so that's basically what's
happening um how do you know when
there's an animal hiding the level do
you just beat the level and it's there
and those are an indication yeah there
is in the hub world they'll show you
that they'll be maybe a paw print on it
that says that there's an animal there
or bones and that'll say those are
animal bones so I'm gonna beat this
level it should unlock a little bit of
story ooh I love the art style um I
don't have this story and subtitles on
so it might not be fully understood to
hear but that's the main character in
the back there and it's kind of a lot to
do with maybe family issues and her
friendship with this fox is basically
the main storyline that we're looking at
here but I just absolutely love the art
style I think it's really beautiful
and I was surprised I know the way from
here with how beautiful and like and
don't know it was a deeper than I
thought it would be I'm running away and
never coming home I hit some snacks in
the treasure box plus Eddie taught me
what's good to eat so we can make it
pretty far in the night if we take the
rowboat oh gosh poor little [ __ ] oh
where are you going choo-choo that's the
main character sister wait where's Iona
oh why is that there yeah it's a mystery
did she put that there that's kind of
not the best place she didn't think this
through did she you never know what a
wild animal there's capable wrong we
need a lot of interesting characters in
this not just from her family but
there's like some neighborhood friends
that you meet along the way a lot of
them give like pretty interesting
trinkets of information something I
really liked about the writing of the
game holy crap okay it's getting really
dark is the writing very dark I think so
i think it's it has elements that are
really honest about relationships and
maybe problems that we have the people
that we love but another thing that I I
really liked about the the writing was
there were some like tidbits of actual
interesting information that I that I
was really glad to learn just about how
lighthouses work and prisms and things
like that so there's actually like
science information in the game that I
was really happy to know so looks like
I've unlocked most of the stars now but
i'll show you may be an elements that
you can see what some of those look like
yeah here's the yes so the above you can
see frostbite there's a paw print that
shows there's an animal there and now
this one it says it's got a little
magical element of Earth so this will be
where I unlost something for Earth so
I'll just show you what they look like
now when you unlock a magical element
what is that do for you that's for your
hair yep it is my hair so now I'm like
I'm said before I'm toggling between my
different properties I'll show you the
green one
earth and as I walk around you'll see a
little earth and leaves going across the
world and so I'll go across the world in
a timely manner oh maybe it doesn't want
me to do that this game actually reminds
me a little bit of Monument Valley and
then it's like short pieces that you can
play in short spurts or you can you know
sit and do this for hours yeah oh my
gosh I feel like most of this game whoa
and it's really showing you that from
the world itself is that it wants you to
explore and just kind of be at peace
here did not go the way I wanted to
didn't want to turn so i'm going to show
you on a different level because i am
absolutely committed to showing you now
okay um okay so i should definitely be
able to doing here i changed it to a
different thing because it changed my
color so here i am changing this as I
promised now the earth is earth it
changes a lot of the different
properties of it i'll show you something
ever the ones this one is ice so as you
know like as remote like most ice things
when I I slide around the earth see that
we kind of like have that little slide
mechanic to it but if I change it to
water here we go now it's a water planet
and i'll show you how that changes the
impact of the so i can actually limply
big trouble getting there you are
married there we go so i can go through
it now cuz its liquid sometimes there'll
be stars hidden in the planet Oh which
means you have to convert them to water
or some other things that you can
actually oh look at that that's cool um
so yeah it's a lot of it is just based
on what you need and using those skills
as you see fit to kind of making them
what you need um yeah i'll show you a
few this other skills i picked up along
the way too I've picked up a double jump
that's pretty nice and pushing up on my
arrows now it makes me free fall it's
kind of like I have more control over my
little girl in space because originally
she's actually pretty floaty and its
really it's not difficult to control but
it's certainly more challenging nice but
once I once you get some of these skills
unlocked it I mean it helps immensely
with your ability to travel through the
world
this looks super super pretty and when
does it come out it's out now it is out
now I think it came out on the 25th or
something yeah so monday so yeah it is
well below yep it's on steam for fifteen
dollars and uh yeah I actually I was
really surprised with how much I enjoyed
it it's it's a surprisingly enjoyable
lovely little game and i would recommend
it i think it's worth checking out
awesome well thanks for showing me this
you're welcome yeah for joining me so
yeah thanks a lot if you guys are
interested in this game you can find it
on steam so thanks for watching